the eight people killed in the attack
include five men from Argentina who were
visiting New York City they were part of
a group celebrating the 30th anniversary
of their high school graduation a sixth
person who died was from Belgium four
people were hurt after the attackers
rented truck crashed into their school
bus we spoke with a man who ignored
gunshots in order to take this video
DeMarco Morgan is near the spot where
the attack ended DeMarco good morning
never good morning to you a
Massachusetts man who met his friends
from Argentina was also hurt in that
attack the tourists were run over by a
truck just moments before it rammed into
that school bus and it all came to an
end I knew that bridge if you can make
it out with the Scylla very active crime
scene at this time one man who captured
video of the mangled bus Toto's what he
witnessed was extraordinary and horrific
firefighters and emergency crews worked
to load those hurt along the lower
Manhattan bike path onto stretchers and
into ambulances five of the victims who
were killed were part of a group of men
from Rosario Argentina northwest of
Buenos Aires wearing shirts proclaiming
the Spanish word for free they posed for
this photo as they set off on the trip
meant to pay tribute to more than three
decades of friendship
one of the victims amongst those killed
in Tuesday's attack was from Belgium I
[Music]
just realized that that guy in the
street had just basically plowed and
t-boned a bus full of kids sebastian
subject took this video moments after
the attackers truck rammed into the
small yellow school bus oh my god
I have to chronicle this I have to see
who's on that bus I have to get the word
out to the parents it's passenger-side
was Kay dead two adults and two students
on the bus were hurt the window was
knocked out it was apparent that one of
the kids flew across that and broke the
window with his head he was bleeding and
then I saw the girl trapped in the wheel
well of that bus and some really pretty
horrific sides subject praised the
efforts of the bus driver the bus driver
I really feel for him you you could tell
he was hurt he was selfless and trying
to get those kids out of the bus he was
in shock most of all the father of three
said he wanted to make sure some of the
attacks youngest victims were safe the
unknown is the terror that all parents
have I've never seen anything like that
and so it's all it's all surreal I'm not
sure I'm gonna sleep tonight the city of
Rosario Argentina has set aside three
days of mourning as a tribute to the man
killed here yesterday meantime the FBI
has posted signs out here asking anyone
with video or any information about
yesterday's incident to call them or
come forward Noora lots of video out
there DiMarco thank you so much for your
reporting